now then with a new coalition spat it
seems every week it might feel like the
general election it's just a few weeks
away
in actual fact as we all know it's not
until May 2015 that's because it was
agreed and then set in stone when David
Cameron and Nick Clegg formed this
government but was that a mistake and
would everyone be better off if we had
an election this year
well I'm joined now by Tony Blair's
former political director Matthew Doyle
you Gove's head of political research
Joe Twyman and the observers chief
political commentator Andrew ronsley
very good to see you all let's discuss
and Andrew that is the point where I
thought there were you know we're
hearing within various departments of
them fighting like cats in a sack you
know the toys are being thrown out of
prams on a regular basis yes I think
this was probably inevitable whenever
the date of the election because as it
came into view both the Liberal
Democrats and the Conservatives would
start to differentiate themselves to be
more aggressive about articulating and
advertising where they differed from
each other so if you imagine it would
only going to be a four year palm and a
four year government I think this
process would have just started a bit
earlier I think both parties have to be
quite careful in that it's not
necessarily a very good advertisement
for them if they get into a lots and
lots of bitter Raz and especially the
Liberal Democrats who told us there's a
great virtue in having a coalition well
it looks so virtuous if they spend the
next 70 months or so tearing each
other's eyes what is to be done you know
for the next 17 months if they if there
is this disjuncture within government
can actually achieve much or they just
got to sit on their hands and pretend
that they're not fighting well I think
this is the the challenge I mean anyone
who's been in government will tell you
that if you know what you want to do
then the time flies by I think the
problem with this government is that
David Cameron gives every sense of
wanting to be Prime Minister but no
sense of knowing why he wants to be
Prime Minister and that's why you've got
this sense of him being sort of buffeted
by his backbenchers buffeted by it by
issues that they want to raise rather
than he wants to raise and not having a
core agenda that he can bring the
national conversation back to and that's
partly why I think the next six
months will feel like we're treading
water hmm I mean Joe you know on the
polling one of the public think of the
current state of the coalition they
quite liked it when it was form didn't
they obviously a novelty yeah I mean it
really depends on which party you
support and if you're if you're
conservative or liberal unsurprisingly a
pretty keen on their on the coalition
government and even amongst those
supporters learn about two-thirds of of
those supporters think that they're
working together quite well if you go
back to before the the election we
tested a whole host of a whole host
different forms of constitutional form
and actually fixed term Parliament's
were the only change that more than half
the the electorate supported and so it's
definitely a popular move and it plays
into simplicity which is which is
something that which is something the
public likes and they don't like the
idea of the government in the day if
you're not having this advantage being
you know that's cool when they want it
so they didn't like the idea of I mean
effectively if the government's didn't
had control when they call the election
budget you know it's not a very race
when the prime minister of the day gets
to father
starting pistol I'm not sure actually
will ever get away from fixed term
Parliament's now because the Prime
Minister would have to go to Parliament
and say I'm going to repeal this
legislation to get back this right this
extra perk of being able to call the day
of the general election I mean labour
hasn't actually said it would repeal
this legislation we made whether you
like them or not
namely stuck with it's never going to
fly because the idea of anyone standing
up saying I would like to take back some
powers
I think slightly counterintuitive thing
about having a fixed term Parliament is
actually it has added to the lame-duck
period that you can see a government
going into before the general election
because it's on the horizon we know it
where it is and so therefore by the very
nature of knowing when it's going to be
it becomes a focal points in a way
previously the the sort of day-to-day
business of government would continue I
think Matthew makes a good point and the
other thing is done on the other side is
it's delayed Labour's process of
thinking through and telling us what its
policies are going to be which would
have happened earlier if you're either
uncertainly the day all you think it's
going to be at for you
Parliament has been quite a lot of delay
in that Jo let's think I was wondering
you know could even add to the public
cynicism about politicians in that you
know I mentioned cut and run budgets
when you could have that budget in the
spring and not call the election for a
few weeks afterwards people might think
there was a general election coming but
you didn't know it now the budget in
particular of March 2015 or whatever it
is we we know what's coming immediately
after that
well that's true to a certain extent but
at the same time it certainly for the
past few elections people have had a
pretty good idea when the elections are
going to be and would things have been
any different this time around have we
not have fixed temperaments probably not
it probably would have stayed the same
course you don't think worth pointing
out it's that actually the public don't
really pay that much attention attention
to the idea of who's calling it or when
it's being called instead it's just it's
just something that exists out there
this is when the election will probably
be or this is where in the election will
definitely be and that's just something
that people it brings it brings into
question here the type of growth I was
hoping to discuss with Douglas cars all
about thinks it's the wrong type of
growth of its consumer and debt LED all
over again
you know there are two arguments about
this that the government needs time for
that to to bed in and really show their
fruits or that it might turn out to be
transitory there's a big external shock
and it all disappears in a year's time I
mean I think at the moment both the
Tories and the Lib Dems are jolly
grateful that they decided to go for a
five-year four-year was discussed when
they have any coalition negotiations
fired you because they needed the extra
time George Osborne especially grateful
I would have thought they needed the
extra time in the hope that recovery
will take out be right it's an
interesting risk for them if in fact
they are inflating too much of a bubble
especially in housing one thing they
don't want to happen is interest rates
to start going up again before the next
general election so if they both Adam
the bubble their timing will be slightly
and they must be conscious of the
mistake that Gordon Brown made which was
having the opportunity to call an
election before of the vast majority if
you like the bad news have begun and not
taking it and so and so that must be
playing on their on their mind so they
don't want to be stuck with with
economic troubles jumping over all over
their back in the run-up to
I think if you asked any of them they'd
say we're really glad it's not gonna be
an election in May of this year the way
things stand
but the biggest risk for both of the
governing parties is under estimating
the public in all of this I mean if they
think that the public is going to sort
of fall for a whole series of symbolic
routes that the two parties have I mean
I think this is one of the times where
the politicians need to give the public
more credit they kind of know what's
going on and they either will buy into
the Liberal Democrat narrative that this
was done because it was necessary or
they will see it as an exercise that
hasn't won how do you personally think
knowing more about the inside I mean do
you think it is being done for cosmetic
reasons we want to show particularly
from the Lib Dems side we want to show
our supporters that there is
differentiation already taking place or
don't they just they just burst out
don't they but you turn front
frustration but you there's you can
either do one of two things you can
either make the argument that this is
necessary it's in the national interest
this is what voters wanted at the last
election or you can go for the approach
of basically saying all the horrible
things that the Tories are doing and
some of them you've managed to round the
corners on them at least they would
claim you know you can't do both you
can't you can't do both I think we'll
end up doing both partly because some of
it is genuine I think especially on
Europe Tories in Lib Dem clearly
disagree some of it is a bit staged it's
a bit like American wrestling's some
people say but nobody's really tell me
Santa isn't under you you know you know
about the inside I mean you know
particularly when it comes to let's say
party conference time isn't some of that
agreed in advance don't Nick David come
and sit down okay will allow you lot to
say that and you can bash me over this
and will bash you over certainly in the
early days yes Gary arm of the wrestling
metaphor you know there be the piledrive
from the slam but it would all be
secretly choreographed beforehand I
think more and more talking to people on
both sides they're actually genuinely
quite a lot of bitterness creeping
because there is there more ambushing
and more attacks that weren't expected
and are really getting quite serious
occasionally you know that if they I'm
saying the Tories didn't warn us they
were going to do that and I suppose that
comes back to the fundamental that I
think even the sort of majority Tory
party of the government is giving the
sense that is his run out of
so therefore there isn't even something
constructive for the two parties to
spark off each other for that's why
you're seeing the rouse over things like
Europe and immigration and so on in the
absence of a substantive debate about
you know schools or health or public
services it's very politically damaging
isn't it Joe if you seem to have run out
of steam run out of ideas you're
rudderless yeah absolutely people like
people like strong visionary politicians
even if they don't think that any are
they also like United parties and they
like the coalition government to be
effective but at the same time the Lib
Dems have to be careful because they
can't they can't be too close to one
party or the other given that the
polling is pointing to at the moment a
very close result in 2015 and so they
can't be seen to be jumping into bed
with with one party only to find out
that they have to be with the others
later on I mean Andrew what are the big
issues to deal with I mean the big issue
at the moment is migration immigration
you know in particular when it comes to
you you but we're not gonna have a
referendum until 2017 exactly if we get
one the other one is the economy and
you've just kind of got to sit back and
hope it well but there are a huge issue
exposed just in the last few days about
further deficit reduction and cuts
George Osborne I think this is a big
stark divide George Osborne saying the
Conservatives would look to find half
the money from non pensioner welfare
benefits both labour and the Liberal
Democrats saying we don't want to do
that I think that's a very important
choice you say that and then you have an
election because you want that to be the
dividing line you don't have to then
bring in the cuts you all right
okay do you support them or don't you
labor if it's not gonna happen I think
you might be bending the one is not
gonna be election and there has to be
pretty extraordinary circumstances where
both the labour and the Conservatives
think it's in their interests to have a
general election for example in anything
we kind of glossed over that point we
kind of missed a bit I think it's about
Labour's policy portfolio there in
particular as Andrews pointing out is
you've got one of the so-called dividing
lines and labour has to not start coming
up with those responses pretty urgently
and in some detail
I totally agree and I think the stuff
that we've seen this weekend for example
from Tristram hunt on teaching and
looking their standards of teaching was
actually the sort of stuff that we need
I think voters are looking for a bit
more red meat from the Labour Party and
you're going to see in the coming
that stuff coming out but I think
there's also a problem for the Labour
Party when it comes to sort of knowing
how to handle the Liberal Democrats that
there always has been which is around
the fact of the Liberal Democrats aren't
actually one party you know the Liberal
Democrat Party in the south where they
win votes off the Tories is very
different to the limit Liberal Democrat
appeal in the north where they're
winning the word winning seats off
labour and those are certainly seats
that Labour expects to pick up at the
next election I just know it's you Joe
Barry you know it's know an appetite do
you feel there you done any polling on
it for for another coalition whichever
parties it may be made up well it's
really difficult difficult so because
people are judging in a hypothetical
hypothetical context and so they like
the idea of collaborative politics but
sometimes they don't they're not so
supportive okay and there we must end it
and we must wait okay - Matthew Doyle
and really thank you all very much
indeed